ils sont gentils
étonnant
gémo c'est l'effroi
incroyable comme le groupe de jeunes
qu'on a en ce moment ils sont
incroyables
non
jours melvin moi j'appelle michael et ne
patience et la danse
présenté
ma mère est lisse bonjour
c'est qui sur la photo là c'est moi
aussi c'est la balise oui je stocke tout
on va dire les
tous les vins des posters les
récompenses
oh la la
ah oui oui oui oui depuis que son petit
séduit parce que ça commençait à 7 ans
l'aîné randy et eux ils étaient déjà
petit et il dansait déjà à quatre ans et
demi en train de le regarder danser ils
dansent et il savait on sentait qu'il
avait envie de suivre l'aîné et c'est
venu comme ça je sais pas un sport comme
les autres c'est une danse espagne dans
cinq lieux comme les autres il ya
plusieurs races différentes musiques la
ceas énergétique et nous bien aimé ça
qu'on cherche donc envoyer les gens
faire des figures de salto cinq ans
aimé voir ça et mes yeux c'est ça qu'on
veut faire en fait ben là c'est en
voulant s'entraîner dans la chambre en
faisant des saltos et les gens atterri
sur le miroir voilà donc juridiquement
seront adultes quand ils vont travailler
vous me rembourser le miroir
ce qu'on ne s'entraîne pas dans les
champs
bon à la danse c'est ta peau des voyages
d'abord c'est d'abord la connaissance on
a connu beaucoup de amis qui sont
maintenant comme des frères pour nous
mm
chante 6-1 6-2
sa descendante il
est intelligent dit ce qui se passe dans
vos orteils au départ je pense que ce
sont des élèves qui n'avaient pas du
tout confiance en eux et qui en grâce au
hip hop ne freine complètement confiance
semble en particulier les films est mené
par les deux jumeaux tout le monde est
en train de progresser énormément dans
leur vie sociale que dans leur vie
scolaire
voilà en france il fallait un minimum
voilà il fallait aller à donner un
minimum d'argent il ya un peu de parents
qui n'ont pas peut-être pas les moyens
de 2
svp de tout projet nécessite des moyens
financiers
et là je trouve les parents doivent se
démener pour fait des actions diverses
afin d'équilibrer le budget la
participation de l'établissement se
résume à l'établissement a en charge les
accompagnateurs
j'aimerais vraiment qu'ils soient
champions france parce que cela
montrerait à tous les gens qui n'ont pas
confiance en eux qu'ils ont vraiment eu
tort et qu'il faut vraiment les aider
l'année prochaine au 7h30 ce soir à
l'entraînement à leurs
jours
on y va donc comme d'habitude on
commence par des hausses des
échauffements ostéo articulaires et on y
va pour les épaules donc on est toujours
en contrôle pas d'accous suivi d'un
parcours d'une vie voilà le grand frère
andy donc il maintenant métro preuves
dans les dix communes ans et voilà je
veux dire
mika menuhin le binôme de ouf
on va partir pour aller jumping jacks
c'est bon mais d'abord on va commencer
par des petits sauts on y va ouais
maintenant échauffement dynamique
vous avez pas en touriste
champion en fait on les apprend qu'est
ce qu'il faut faire pour devenir
champion mais on le re on leur inculque
pas l'obligation de venir chanter c'est
à dire notre philosophie c'est on
apprend à gagner on n'est pas obligé
viany je vous envoie vous partant tiki
taka donc c'est spontanéité et
musicalité danser au sol pour monter
des conflits
les compteurs sont pauvres
pour moi là donc c'est un bon choix
parce que gaza mais sa fin c'est ça nous
aide pour le physique ça nous a aussi
admis à l'époque des belles personnes
parce que y'en a des masses heureux
ordonne en général ils valent pas un
signe pas on voit pas ainsi nous
éviterons et on a une salle où
s'entraînent les intéressés dehors pour
nous c'est des graines de champions en
fait le champion du monde ou autres par
rapport à leur manière d'être et comme
dit gopal tout à l'heure ils sont
incroyables qu'ils ont ça porte
tellement de choses positives que on
sait que ils peuvent aller le plus loin
possible ils se sentent inclus
dans un groupe d'adultes en gardant leur
place d'enfant s'ils font que finalement
quand il ya les horaires pour arriver en
cours ils sont là à l'heure il arrive à
l'avance on travaille beaucoup sur la
concentration on travaille beaucoup
surtout ce qui va leur permettre de
devenir à l'avenir de l'île de la
réunion parce qu'aujourd'hui autant ils
sont forts en danse mais comme ce sont
des quand même des gamins ils peuvent
changer de discipline on veut juste que
ce qu'on leur inculque des valeurs qui
leur permettent de devenir des
le futur de l'ue de la
rivale et au bout de ce projet parce que
qui a une bonne aventure c'est une
aventure ça le mot en fait à trouver
de pouvoir participer à beaucoup de
choses en tant que danseur et 2 aussi le
niveau là en france je crois que c'est
vraiment ça c'est à dire que même si on
croit que c'est impossible c'est
possible
toujours partagé
j'espère qu'ils vont s'amuser
c'est très chiant
viva la vida eres
on profite le maximum pour rêver ou
c'est la réalité
les deux ont rêvé réalité
la réalité paraît donc
gpt pt